Welcome to the lesson one assignments. I'm Andy Brown
and I'm a Udacity course designer. I've been working with
[UNKNOWN] Isabelle to design these lessons, these end of lesson
assignments and our intention was that they be taken in
order. Lesson one, assignment, lesson two, assignment. But you
don't have to do it that way. These assignments will
take a little while. For this lesson, we expect maybe
an hour and a half, if you're doing it thoroughly.
And depending on why you're taking this class, you may not need to do that.
If you're a designer who is just interested
in seeing what's going on in the world
of design, you probably don't need to do all of this. But if you are a
developer and you do want to increase your
design skills, the only way is through practice.